I'm L Stanfield this is the wired
autocomplete
interview what are the people wanting to
know
huh all right where is leit Stanfield
from I am from San Bernardino California
what happened to the
Stanfield and get out I played Andre and
I played Logan what happened to Andre is
he got his body possessed by Logan work
with Jordan was amazing I mean he's just
super smart he had just like this really
big Vision that was cool at the time we
hadn't heard or seen of anything like
that so I think we were just all really
excited to try and make something new
make something special it was good to
know that the world resonated with the
content that we were making in that
people were genuinely interested and
frightened by the movie it's good if you
were frightened by get out if you're not
frightened yeah how did Leith
Stanfield get famous I think I started
first recognizing that people understood
who I was on a sort of larger sense when
I played Snoop and Straight Out of
Compton get out really also was one in
Atlanta where I realized people started
just recognizing me from it so there was
this time where I was in the museum and
I was surveying some things in the
museum and I turned my head around and
there's this person standing right in
front of me surveying me um but they
kind of had like a dead pan face look
and I was like hi how are you and they
were like I was like okay and they were
like I'll let you go and then they
walked
off I was thankful for being
released Lei
Stanfield anime I did a movie uh Called
Death Note where I played a a detective
named l a character in this anime and
that was really fun and it was an
opportunity to play an interesting
character and I had had a lot of fun
doing it also I I really like Dragon
Ball Z Le
Stanfield oh there's two as Snoop I
played Snoop they had me in some like
platform shoes cuz I wasn't quite as
tall as Snoop so they had Chucks but
they were like high heill kind of Chucks
hard to walk in them things I got the
roll uh in the morning at like 5:00 a.m.
they called me and I had to be on set at
like 10 so I had 5 hours of prep time I
just watched all the videos I could
watch of Snoop and just tried to like
really get his mannerisms and it was
important for me to get his voice down
and so I just kept listening to his
interviews I met Snoop after the movie
on the red carpet and uh someone had
recognized me and wanted to bring me
over to Snoop and we got through these
layers of security and there was just
like this wall of weed smoke and then
when the smoke cleared there was Snoop
and I was looking at his torso because
he's actually tall and then I looked up
and there he was leit Stanfield College
I went to Victor Valley College and in
uh Victorville I was kind of finally
like leaving the nest a little bit
discovering more that I wanted to pursue
acting and so I was in the drama program
there eventually I I just decided I I
want to try my hand at pursuing acting
so I dropped out and um just went like
straight to living in my car to
auditioning and stuff like that the
Keith
Stanfield cats audition this audition
was really fun I got to dress up I put
on like all these tights and I put on a
wig I did my own hair my own makeup I
drove past this wig shop and I saw
something in the display and I was like
this would be perfect so I made a little
like Mohawk out of it like a afro Hawk
then I started shaking them hips and I
actually got a call back but as you can
see I didn't make the
cut does Leith
Stanfield have a face tattoo I do have a
face tattoo I have two
actually come
here there's one right here which is an
anchor represents being grounded and
then there is another one up here that
is Magnolia which is one of my favorite
flowers I have a lot of tattoos I
tattoos all over my arms on my Knuckles
on my on my chest my leg I guess I
really just like writing on myself I got
my first tattoo when I was uh 17 my
first tattoo was my mother's name so she
wouldn't be mad she still was mad does
Leith
Stanfield make music yes I do thank you
for asking I'm going to be releasing
some soon my music name is my name's
backwards which I guess I best pronounce
as I love making music I've been making
music since even before I started acting
just kind of like you know in the
driveway of my mom's house you know
beating on pots and pans and coming up
with these Melodies and ideas and so
more to come on music keep your eyes
peeled Leith
Stanfield new
movie The Book of Clarance yes January
12th coming to a theater near you see it
in theaters honestly truthfully it's
like it's one of those ones you want to
see on the big screen there action
there's dancing there's love there's
romance there's fighting and the best
part is it all takes place in Jerusalem
in 29 ad theith
Stanfield Knives Out yeah Knives Out was
fun we shot that in Boston it was really
cold I played a detective I was being
inspired by all the different actors and
people that I got to sit next to that
was really cool and then we uh went to
Chris Evans house and rode on ATV and it
was quite
fun Leith
Stanfield personality let me know when
you find it I like to have fun I'm silly
I also am like deeply kind of I take
everything seriously I just try to try
to treat people well the Keith
Stanfield fashion it's all about the
Luke my whole thing is just having fun
comfortability I like to do different
things I like to dress up this is a
scarf but it's like a quilt scarf I
think that's pretty cool it's like it's
a quarf or squill Lei Stanfield Teddy
Perkins I was on Atlanta and I Was
preparing to shoot the day before and I
saw on the call sheet there was this guy
named Teddy Perkins it was Teddy Perkins
being played by Teddy Perkins so I was
like who is the actor and uh Productions
like Teddy Perkins and I googled Teddy
Perkins and I was like who is this and
nothing came up and I was very confused
I was like he's an actor how long has he
been acting the next day I show up on
set there's no one in the makeup trailer
except me so I'm like okay I go to set
and there's this guy standing his back
to me he has like long hair he turns
around in this like strange way and this
is Teddy Perkins and I'm confused cuz I
still don't know who this is and I'm
like Hi how are you he's like Hi how are
you and then I looked at his feet and
his feet were standing in a similar
fashion that I know Donald generally
stands and so I thought that that was
weird but I didn't really think much of
it I mean his eyes were blue he didn't
look like him up close I was like and
then one of the crew members finally
told me that's Donald and I was at the
same time in awe and shocked as I was
disappointed because then the illusion
was gone and I thought how good would
that illusion have been to just not know
who this person is and the whole cast
and crew had conspired for me not to
know and it was successful up until that
point and I still have not and will not
release that person's name
theith
Stanfield sorry to bother you we shot
that in Oakland we had very little money
I was changing in a van eating in that
same van but I loved the fact that we
were working so hard towards something
that we all believed in and it made
every moment worth it and I wouldn't
take back a second of what I experienced
making that movie The Voice aspect of
the movie was really interesting because
basically we would be saying a line and
then it would
just turn into that just like moving
your lips and then they went back in in
ADR and added the voice later but I
trusted boots and I knew we were making
something fun hopefully that people
would enjoy so yeah it was super fun
with Keith
Stanfield uncut gems shout out with Adam
Sandler who's amazing just a brilliant
beautiful person you know with the
safties I had Liberty to kind of uh
perform without boundaries they had
several cameras set up and basically
just gave us a scenario and was like
play the scenario and somehow they were
able to edit that and I don't know how
they were able to edit that footage
especially with the audio perhaps that
lended to the chaotic feel lit
Stanfield voice acting and I've done it
a few times as on BoJack Horseman I did
a show called yasuke it's quite
different from uh acting on screen and
so it's a muscle that I realized like I
really need to develop and like you know
just continue to work at it and get
better shouts out voice acting hello the
stand field sza video yeah uh had a lot
of fun doing a video with sza she's
amazing artist great collaborator and um
I love her music and so I knew of s
music and you know um we we had talked a
little bit about like spirituality and
going to like spiritual Retreats and
like meditation and things like that
she's a real spiritual person one time
she just asked me to be in a video and I
was like yeah so um you know when she
calls him
around sorry
it's really interesting what people are
interested in so that was
[Music]
fun